do you feel happy in love I'm not in
love do you wish you were in love yeah
okay and have you been married before no
but you want to be married
I don't know just look at me and say I
am in love I am in love okay say it
again I am in love I feel like you're
single you know what you're married
aren't you
is that right are you asking yeah I'm
saying okay I mean I am single like I
don't know if I want a relationship like
I'm I am afraid of rejection yeah I am
protecting my heart there's like this
wall I do feel like there was a
heartbreak in the past I I don't know I
keep seeing something in the past you
give the vibe of
not being fully open so that might just
be that you protect your heart or you're
afraid of opening your heart so I don't
want you to be too afraid okay so I
don't want you to be too afraid okay